russia has stepped up its bombardments
of ukraine's capital kiev a number of
strikes have hit a residential
neighborhood it's unclear if there were
any casualties local authorities say at
least five people were killed yesterday
a 35-hour curfew is now in place
russia has also launched new assaults on
the port city of mariupol the united
nations says 3 million people have now
fled ukraine in a show of solidarity
three eastern european leaders visited
cave on tuesday
in kiev as the russian advance nears
ukrainian soldiers have taken time to
bury the fallen
here they are laying to rest to comrade
who was killed resisting the russians in
boris spill outside kiev as ukrainians
watch the ceremony they know that there
will be many more funerals before the
guns fall silent
[Music]
while little sign of a peaceful solution
is in sight president zielenski said he
saw a glimmer of hope for compromise in
talks with russia even as moscow stepped
up its bombardment of the capital
it is important it's difficult but
important because any war ends in an
agreement
meetings continue
as i'm told the positions in the
negotiations sound more realistic
however there still needs to be more
time for decisions to be in ukraine's
interests
meanwhile hailing glory to ukraine the
polish czech and slovenian prime
ministers became the first foreign
leaders to visit kiev since russia's
invasion
all three are former communist
territories which are now members of the
eu and nato they reiterated their desire
to give ukraine a way to join the eu as
soon as possible
i hope it should be agreed over the next
couple of
days or weeks and the candidate status
should be given till the end of this
year at the latest
thank you
the three-week-old conflict has cranked
up cold war level tensions between
moscow and the west and driven more than
three million ukrainians fleeing across
the border to seek refuge
zielenski also addressed a key concern
used by vladimir putin to justify the
invasion of russia's ex-soviet neighbour
by saying ukraine should accept that it
would not become a member of the nato
defense alliance
ukraine is not a member of nato
we understand that we've heard for years
that the doors were open but we also
heard that we could not join
it's a truth and it must be recognized
there's movement elsewhere in the west
zalenski said he would address the us
congress later on wednesday and joe
biden will visit europe next week to
shore up nato's unity as war rages on
its eastern flank
let's bring in dw correspondent
alexandra von naaman in la viv alexandra
there's been increased shelling as we
just heard in and around the capital
keeve what is happening there in the
capital
there are reports about heavy fighting
on the outskirts of kiev explosions in
the city center residential areas were
apparently hit by russian
earth strikes
and the russian forces are trying to
tighten their grip on the city
and that is why the city's mayor
announced a curfew that it's going to
last for 35 hours he urged all residents
to seek shelter to take cover vitaly
klitschko however also published a
statement saying that
the city is not going to give in to give
up that the russians can take buildings
but not the people of kiev
alexander yesterday we saw three eastern
european leaders visit zielinski in cave
at huge personal risk how significant
was that visit
well taking or given the situation in
kiev the decision to travel to the
ukrainian capital was a very bold move
and a highly symbolic gesture that was
praised by the ukrainian president he
said that having such such friends and
partners
make sure that ukraine is going to win
the war however we also have to stress
what they talked about and in terms of
substance
their talk about sanctions new sanctions
against russia
that is likely to happen they talked
about
use
humanitarian help and eu's assistance to
rebuild ukraine that is also likely to
happen once we will have peace however
other topics they were that were on the
agenda
the proposal by the polish vice prime
minister kaczynski to
have sort of peacekeeping force on the
ground in ukraine with nato forces
supporting this mission is not very
likely to happen anytime
now you're in la viv in the west of
ukraine are people there worried that
the violence the shelling the
bombardments that we're seeing elsewhere
will soon reach that part of the country
yes people here are worried they are
scared uh they believe that anything can
happen and we saw just just a few days
ago that russian forces attacked
military infrastructure
training and peacekeeping center and not
far away from lev and only about 20
kilometers away from the polish border
so people are aware of that and this
night we had to seek shelter we had an
eight a raid alarm twice this night so
people are scared of course
now as we heard in our report just prior
to speaking to you president zielinski
said he believes russia may now be more
open to negotiations that their position
as he put it may be more is more
realistic now
is that overly hopeful do you think
it could be but of course that's a
message that is uh needed in ukraine uh
in this time of of uh suffering and and
desperation and and we also also have to
stress that there has been some progress
in the talks between the ukrainian and
russian delegations we saw that
yesterday two thousand uh vehicles were
able to leave the city of maripo the
city that is under siege so this is
really uh progress taking into account
how desperate the situation there is
when we talk about uh talks about a
potential ceasefire this is a long way
to go i would say and we'll see whether
uh the ukrainian uh
government or its delegation will be
able to to make any progress on that
talking to the russian delegation all
right dw correspondent alexander von
norman thank you very much
well let's turn now to dw's russia
analyst roman gotcha renko he's speaking
to us from bonn roman president
zielinski as we were just talking about
there discussing with alexandra says
that russian demands during the talks
are becoming more realistic
do we know what russia's position is and
whether it has indeed shifted
well at this moment we have no details
from those negotiations so we can only
speculate and analyze so what we heard
from russia before or during the
previous rounds of negotiations that
russia insisted for example that ukraine
acknowledged crimea the annexed crimea
as part of russia russia was also
suggesting that ukraine should
acknowledge those so-called people's
republics in eastern ukraine of donetsk
and luhansk as independent states
so we don't hear such demands anymore
and we can assume that maybe russia has
dropped them
uh what we've heard for example from the
russian representative at the un
um
are the key three demands that russia is
still sticking to and those are
that um ukraine should be
denasificated this is how russia puts it
probably meaning that there are some
some
extremists
in power in ukraine which is of course
not the case
um russia also insists on the
demilitarizing ukraine and this is what
we see from the very beginning russian
army striking military objects ukraine
but not only military objects of course
and um russia also wants ukraine to put
into its constitution to write down
the passage that it will not be part of
nato and this is what we've heard from
the ukrainian president
that maybe ukraine
is no more uh pursuing that goal but he
didn't say it quite like that he said
that maybe it will be difficult and that
he is disappointed so i think there is
some movement but in the key question
for ukraine now which is humanitarian
corridors there has been little progress
some but little
ukraine claims russia has been
escalating its bombardment of civilian
targets do you think that's a strategic
move of course of course it's a
strategic move and i think russia is
trying to terrorize ukraine to terrorize
ukrainian population uh to force some
concessions from the government for in
kiev and to force ukraine um
to to to move on some some key issues
for russia and of course uh the second
aim i think is to um
to
move ukrainians uh to to become refugees
to leave the country
to block the roads to to maybe um create
difficulties for you of the ukrainian
army and and this is this is what i
think is the goal but it is not working
because ukrainian government is still
fighting and i think it will not give up
it will not yield to russian demands and
even those terrible air strikes that
we've seen for three weeks now um that
they will not um lead for for ukraine to
change its position
roman we don't have much time left but i
wanted to ask you just domestically what
effect this invasion and the
international sanctions are having on
russians
shortly just one example the effect of
sanctions is really growing day by day
and i hear news that russians are really
worried that they will not be having
enough enough um
supplies of
things for their daily needs uh for
example things like pampers for kids
russians are trying to to buy as many as
they can as long there are some steel in
russian shops so we see
spare parts for cars um
some medical equipment some some
medicine
you you name it and there is a huge huge
shortage of such things in russia in the
coming days and weeks i think this is
something russia underestimated
roman goncharenko from dw russian
department thank you very much for the
analysis
two journalists working for the u.s
network fox news have been killed in
ukraine irish cameraman pierre
zakrashevsky seen here at the front of
this photo and ukrainian producer
alexandra kovchinova died when their
vehicle the vehicle they were traveling
in came under fire outside kiev fox news
said another reporter has been
hospitalized at least four journalists
have died covering the conflict since it
began about three weeks ago
the european union has imposed a new
round of sanctions against russia aimed
at stifling financing of its invasion of
ukraine the measure measures also hit
the inner circle of president vladimir
putin dw's christine mundo has more from
brussels
as russia continues to barrage ukraine
with bombs the european union has
delivered its latest blow to the kremlin
with a fresh round of sanctions
they're designed to punish moscow for
the death and devastation it has brought
on its neighbor
the measures will be felt in russia by
both the ordinary and the elite
they include banning the export of
luxury goods to russia
stopping steel product imports from
russia
freezing the assets of the billionaire
oligarch roman abramovich and others
close to vladimir putin
and denying russia's special trading
access into the eu market
the eu says this new round of sanctions
will put more economic pressure on the
kremlin further crippling its ability to
finance the invasion into ukraine but
the bloc is still sending hundreds of
millions of euros into russia's coffers
every single day
that money is payment for the oil and
gas europe buys from russia to keep the
heating and lights on
banning russia's energy would deal a
heavy blow to its economy but it would
also hurt ordinary europeans who are
already seeing the cost of their living
soil we have to find a solution how we
as
soon as we can face out of this foster
few deliveries but for the moment it is
still extremely difficult but this would
make of course a huge impact because
right now every day we transfer seven to
eight hundred million euros
on the state budget or to the state
budget of russia
since the end of february the west has
imposed thousands of sanctions on russia
for its aggression towards ukraine in
just weeks russia has overtaken iran to
become the most sanctioned country in
the world
it's not clear if this pressure will be
enough to force russia to stop
now to some other stories making news
around the world credit rating companies
have suggested that russia may be on the
verge of defaulting on its foreign
currency debt that's after international
sanctions limited its ability to access
foreign exchange reserves moscow is due
to pay over 117 million dollars in
interest on sovereign bonds on wednesday
with more payments looming later in the
month u.s president joe biden signed a
budget bill into law on tuesday it
includes 13.6 billion dollars in
additional military and humanitarian aid
to ukraine the white house confirmed
that biden will travel to brussels next
week to attend an extraordinary nato
summit to discuss the crisis
the council of europe has voted to expel
russia as a member the pan-european body
has the mission to uphold human rights
and the rule of law the vote came hours
after russia said it was pulling out